I've been talking to you about what's
happening on college campuses and the
issues of anti Israeli bias on college
campuses and also the issue of
anti-semitism on college campuses now to
be super clear being anti Israeli is not
inherently anti-semitic there is overlap
in those two movements in those two
ideologies but every time we talk about
this I get emails being anti Israeli or
critiquing Israeli foreign policy or
domestic policy that is not inherently
anti-semitic but it has served as cover
for anti-semites in many cases now let's
discuss the term occupation for a second
the term occupation is typically used in
relation to the current situation in
Israel with regard to Gaza and the Gaza
blockade as well as the West Bank right
so there are debates over is what's
happening in Israel now an occupation of
Gaza and the West Bank is what's
happening in Israel now a logical
reaction to the security concerns that
are well documented with regard to
attacks on Israelis and Israel this is a
question that often comes up
however Portland State University's
Student Senate went a step further
showing that they know absolutely
nothing about what's going on in Israel
bypassing one of these boycott and
divestment resolutions which alleges
that Israel has been occupying
Palestinian land since its establishment
in 1948 and that all Israeli companies
and companies that work with the Israeli
military must be void boycotted now this
isn't just Portland State University in
language that is similar in a BDS
resolution from the National Women's
Studies Association they wrote and I'll
put the quote up on the screen for you
here whereas the Israeli occupation of
Palestinian land has been entrenched
since 1948 during the 1948 Palestine war
over 700,000 Palestinians were expelled
etc etc again the occupation starting in
1948 wait a second what we can have a
discussion about whether the current
situation the
current situation is a willy-nilly
occupation or a situation required by
the security realities in the area or
somewhere in between right that's a very
legitimate and important conversation to
have the idea that Israel's mere
creation is the occupation is laughably
out of this world and I would love to
talk to some of these women's studies
individuals who pass this resolution or
people from the Portland State
University State Senate that passed this
resolution it's like they think one day
israel appeared and confiscated
sovereign Palestinian land and I've said
this before and it bears repeating
countries are created one of three ways
on this planet this applies to all
countries one annexation or purchased
that's one way in which countries are
created to war or invasion or takeover
and three international treaty Israel
was created by international treaty its
existence is no more or less legitimate
than the existence of any other country
if you are going to not do business with
companies that do business with Israel
based on Israel being an occupying force
not because of what's going on now in
Gaza and the West Bank but from its mere
creation in 1948 you should not be doing
business with any American company
whatsoever
because by that same logic this entire
thing we call the United States of
America most of it and and the part that
was purchased was purchased at a
pittance pittance from pittance that's a
kind of difficult word to say for a very
small amount of money a total ripoff
right from from natives that were here
before Europeans came and you could
argue that it is just as much of an
occupation as what's going on in Israel
but I want to go further right because
there's a lot of people who don't even
realize that Israel was not created from
land that wasn't previously some
Palestinian country this goes back to
understanding the history of the British
Empire controlling the land and this
goes back even further to the Ottoman
Empire it involves Jordan it is far more
complex than any harebrained resolution
from the National Women's Studies
Association or the Portland State
Universities
state Senate would be but the bigger
picture is that this is a pointless
resolution in June Portland State
President when we will called the
resolution divisive and ill-informed but
he also said that there is no practical
effect here at all since the funds for
the university are not managed by the
state Senate this is a declaration a
boycott a sanction that has absolutely
no impact whatsoever period so this is a
waste of time on something that is both
pointless and factually incorrect and
it's really sad that this nonsense is
happening on college campuses across the
country